answers are cheap right we can just say
hey Google how far is Timbuktu from
Kathmandu Timbuktu is 8985 kilometers
from Kathmandu as the crow flies
we just killed curiosity in that moment
right so answers are cheap assumptions
are really dangerous right there's a
time where somebody reached out to see
if I was available to speak at an event
and they showed the acronym of their
conference and I looked it up and it
looked like it was going to be a bunch
of FBI agents all gathered in the same
place it turns out that was a different
conference and they had the same acronym
as one and I made the Assumption so I
hopped on this call and I did my
homework beforehand
and we're chatting and it's like 10
minutes into the conversation I'm like
don't I did not expect this from you
turns out it was an education conference
very different lens very different
framing the entire premise of my work
and my late co-authors work around
asking powerful questions when we ask
powerful questions we have the ability
to increase the psychological safety
that exists in an organization which
research would say is actually the
number one predictor of high performing
teams I would also say that fear is the
enemy of curiosity right so if you want
an Engaged organization where people are
curious and taking initiative and
accountability for what they want you
don't want a lot of fear and when we
Foster and encourage and build curiosity
it actually Roots out fear when a group
really understands deeply and is
practicing asking really great powerful
questions it creates a learning
organization and a learning organization
is one that doesn't die the moment that
you or your organization stops learning
is the moment that you start dying
Ukrainian culture where people are
asking powerful questions and creating
conversations that matter also actually
fundamentally increases retention I was
actually working with a group of 25 C
videos once in a workshop in
Philadelphia and all the same size
company and they didn't know this but I
went and printed off
hundreds of their reviews off of
Glassdoor right the site that people go
to when they rage quit and type in all
caps about how terrible your
organization is or how great it is or
whatever else I had hundreds of these
reviews printed off and for the workshop
um I anonymized them so nobody knew
whose company they were talking about
and I cut these out and I had them
placed on tables all around the room and
their first tasks when they walked in
the room was hey everybody I've printed
out all of your Glassdoor reviews your
goal is to sort these reviews into
buckets and chunks to try to figure out
why do people stay at your organizations
and why do people leave and one of the
things that was even surprising to me
that they found is that nine out of 10
reviews had the word listen in them or a
synonym for it so the model from our
book asked powerful questions
is designed to create this right to
create an organization where people are
willing to know each other they see each
other hear each other they really get
each other ultimately with each other
both from an internal perspective and
from a customer client-facing
perspective now the problem is if we've
got a magic wand we would just wave it
and then we'd create that the problem is
that magic wand doesn't exist which is
why will and I spent some time thinking
about how to create it and so the flip
side of this pyramid is a series of
skills tools and mindsets
to help you Foster a culture that looks
like this and when you have a culture
like that and people are asking
questions that are rooted in empathy and
rooted in their own curiosity it also
tends to reduce implicit bias and
Prejudice in an organization so we have
this desire to create more inclusive
cultures where people feel a sense of
belonging those are really good words
but as far as implementing them we need
practical skills and tools to be able to
practice that in all the small moments
of a 40 hour plus work week just talking
with a neuroscientist recently Eve Dr
Eve Miller and she was saying and
echoing and re-reminding me that how
much our brains are actually wired our
amygdala right the part that fight or
flight
is wired for belong wired for connection
I think instead of a fight flight or
freeze method our brains have actually
adapted now in a modern era for a fight
flight or a need to be liked or a need
to be right in this culture to make a
long story longer I typically work with
organizations in three different levels
of how to ask powerful questions from
coming in and doing a kickoff keynote
really infusing this culture giving
everybody an experience and then
following up with a guided Journal
materials Etc or where we do a little
bit more of a deep dive where I come do
a kickoff create an experience and all
of this but then remotely or in person
we have follow-ups diving deeper into
each one of these skills practicing that
so that the moment they leave my session
they're actually using the tools and the
language that we experienced in their
next meeting in their next one to one
Etc and then the third level that I tend
to work with people at is on a deeper
ongoing context where we create a series
of smaller group coaching Labs where we
download all this content experience all
this content practice it but come back
every so often to offset the curve of
forgetfulness and talk about okay how is
this really looking in your organization
if this sounds interesting you want to
bring some fun and positive and really
practical professional development to
your own organization School University
or event reach out I would love to help
convert some of the exclamation points
and sentences that end in periods to
sentences that end in question marks in
your organization
have an awesome day